[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday November 9th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
imagine you got a text message out of
the blue from an unknown number
something like sorry I'm running late or
are we going to the salon tonight
maybe you tell that person they've got
the wrong number
but any kind of response could open you
up to a scam that's cost people Millions
so how can a seemingly innocuous text go
on to become a massive possibly
life-changing Shakedown
joining us to discuss this is our cyber
security reporter Robert McMillan hi Bob
thanks for coming back on Tech news
briefing hi Zoe very happy to be here
okay so we know this starts with an out
of the blue message from a stranger
well you get it's like a wrong number
right I have a dog that needs to be seen
by a vet can you help me right away and
then you write back and you say I'm
sorry I think you have the wrong number
and then very quickly you get like a
photograph of a young attractive looking
person and a couple of messages just
saying oh silly me you know I have the
sick animal and sort of a couple of
things that are like lures to see if
you'll keep the conversation going now
if you don't respond then it's over but
if they've somehow intrigued you it
becomes the beginning of what seems to
be sort of an innocuous conversation
with a stranger over the Internet okay
so once you have a relationship with the
stranger that's developed over text or I
assume over other messaging services as
well yeah it's not just text although
those are the ones I seem to be getting
the most uh but you could get one of
these messages via Facebook LinkedIn is
actually a pretty popular way to do it
because they can sort of mine your
LinkedIn information and then 10 that
they worked at the same company as you
or went to the same College as you so
you get these messages and the
relationship might build over a couple
of days or up to a week and then they
pull the trigger and try to get you to
buy crypto crypto huh I mean it feels
like these days everybody's trying to
get me to buy crypto Bob so how do these
scammers make that transition how do
they convince these strangers to buy
crypto all right to be perfectly clear
I'm not trying to get you to buy crypto
so what happens is just in the course of
talking about who you are and who they
are they will present themselves as very
financially successful and secure people
who have made millions of dollars using
these trading systems and they'll start
asking you have you ever heard of
cryptocurrency have you ever wondered
about it and ideally you're somebody
who's maybe heard of it but doesn't know
that much about it and so then they
become kind of your crypto Sherpa
encouraging you and walking you through
the process of first of all acquiring it
and then ultimately sending it to them
as part of a scam you buy some crypto
probably on a legitimate exchange but
then they get you to transfer it to a
fake exchange a website that they
control where it looks like you have a
brokerage account and it looks like
you're making tons of money on this fake
website ultimately to get your money
back they start imposing a bunch of
things that cost you more money so
there's a fee that you have to pay or
you have to pay taxes and so the idea is
the more that you trust this person the
more you are invested in just paying
that extra hundred thousand dollars that
little bit more to get your money out
and to make the whole thing end does
this kind of scam have a name oh this is
called Pig butchering because the
scammers fatten up their victims first
wow
you know you spoke to some of the
victims of these crimes who are they and
what did they say their experience was
like well they tend to be people with
money you know so middle-aged people
maybe a little bit you know empty
nesters maybe a little bit kind of
looking for somebody to chat with the
victims I spoke with were all
professionals you know they were smart
people but people who were neophytes in
the world of cryptocurrency and I think
a lot of them felt like there was this
trend that had passed them by now it's
interesting to note that a lot of
victims were hit when crypto was on the
way up and people were feeling like they
were missing out and what law
enforcement investigators tell me now is
now that there's sort of a crypto winter
and everybody's losing money on crypto
the pitch has become well you can short
sell the crypto so you can actually make
money on the decline of crypto so they
get you either way
Bob one of the victims Jane Yan who you
interviewed also spoke with our sister
podcast the journal this is how she
described feeling after losing 1.6
million dollars in the scam
it's been six months now I'm doing a
little better than before
[Music]
my anxiety level is still high I Wake
Middle night and my heart aches
it just pain there even I try to say
nothing about it and try to say I'm
going to be moving forward
but the thoughts still there you know I
feel it's it's very painful
we saved for our life just hope we have
a secure future
you know not handing over to a criminal
you know she sounds obviously devastated
but it also sounds like these scammers
are you know quite intelligent the idea
that they're sort of shifting their
pitch what do we know about them
well there are a couple of groups that
have investigated them and what they
have told me is that they are largely
based out of Asia that some of the
scammers work in these sort of compounds
they're almost like free trade zones
where you can set up a business so often
Chinese run maybe working out of
Cambodia and they have just like little
office Towers you know filled with
scammer employees who are sending out
these pitches they're often following a
script that is very carefully crafted
they will do things that you might not
expect from a scammer like if you want
to talk to them on the phone they'll do
that if you want to have a video
conference they'll do that too could
this scam exist without cryptocurrency
oh yeah I mean crypto is like the latest
Twist on it but these kind of scams have
been around for a while they're called
confidence scams sometimes they're
called romance scams the FBI says that
the broad category of all these scams
took in nearly a billion dollars last
year from the U.S victims who reported
it if it wasn't crypto they would be
convincing you that they were in trouble
in London and they needed you to get a
bunch of Amazon gift cards sent to them
or wired the money crypto is just
extremely fast it's a great way of
moving money across International
borders and it's become very easy to use
so you don't actually have to even leave
your home to become swindled by this so
then how difficult is it for a law
enforcement to stop these kinds of scams
or to hold the scammers accountable oh
it's like so much of the criminal
activity on the internet like it often
occurs in jurisdictions where U.S law
enforcement really has a hard time or
can't even reach the perpetrators so
they're not going to be able to stop it
the thing that's interesting to me is
that law enforcement has had some
success in recovering funds crypto funds
because you can send the money very
quickly the law enforcement
investigators can trace it back very
quickly and if the money ends up in an
exchange we would just legitimately run
law enforcement can send in a node and
say hey freeze this money don't send it
anywhere else we think it's illegally
obtained and they've had some success
not a ton but some success actually
getting money back all right that's our
cyber security reporter Robert McMillan
Bob thanks so much for joining us always
a pleasure to talk to you
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]